[Musique]
il est temps de passer à une caméra
cachée à vous allez voir là on rentre
dans un film fully alors franchement
benjamin castaldi
matthieu delormeau la femme de benjamin
castaldi et jean pierre castaldi
le père de benjamin qui est avec nous ce
soir applaudissements pour lui la
victoire
[Applaudissements]
vous
merci aujourd'hui remercier l'état leurs
kilos sur le dos merci péter la gueule
on va regarder un bar jamais te pète la
gueule chérie disent je lutte toujours
et encore tu me fais ta gueule après je
te le jure mon bébé pour l'instant sont
embrasés de merci d'être là et les côtés
mais aux côtés de benjamin jean rabasse
jean-pierre ça va il a failli tomber une
perte a vécu une expérience et les mêmes
exceptionnel d'oise à main tu as fait
croire qu'il était en couple avec
matthieu delormeau et invité chez lui
regardez la rivière en revanche je
pensais honnêtement quand on a préparé
le square garden d'abord je n'ai jamais
il va y croire
bach ferme à mathieu c'est une grande
histoire dans tp regarde et regarde
alors benjamin castaldi
il va nous faire une révélation dont
j'ignorais je pensais pas que ça
existait enfin je pensais pas que vous
étiez également
c'est en train de changer de fanfares je
vous surprendre ce serait mathieu
delahousse
[Musique]
pardon et 18 kw mais trois mois et de
3,4 au reggae et quoi ça va de glace
plutôt maintenant l'aventuré sans
problème c'est que vous avez habité
longtemps chez lui donc voilà ouais sauf
qu'à l'époque je ne savais pas qui quoi
je vois là on est ensemble je vous dis
personne et on sent qu'ils étaient et
matthieu delormeau d'air il embrasse
bernard montiel aussi qu'ils ne
regardent pas ce qu'il a fait de très
belles et bien sûr et bien
en bref c'est même mon voyage chez m on
a voulu faire croire à votre père que
vous étiez ensemble
regardez ça jure j'en ai pleuré de rire
benjamin castaldi matthieu delormeau
première partie c'est maintenant ah
ouais
[Musique]
oh
o o obama
j'oubliais les inquiète pas tiens on va
pas donner tout ce magma bonne plus ne
mettra pas j'attends quelqu'un mais
c'est un peu
heureusement c'est un chouïa la merde
c'est un peu la merde c'est un peu
compliqué quoi un mail je me suis là
parce que c'est pas une bombe et se
moque c'est très drôle
c'est un peu tendu avec aurore parce que
j'ai reçu sa de jean phi et descendent
des photos écouter obligé très compliqué
à gérer
et avec elles toile etc
enfin comment comment je vais faire des
jeux et apparaît comme ça va être papa
opportunisme ou pas m ou par contre tu
vas faire comme égal et je prête à rien
enfin dernière laisse on arrive à
reconnaître les marchés tu vas quitter
tout seul avec matthieu delormeau
mais avec quatre enfants trois divorces
et peut pas payer cette annonce c'est
aussi pour ça et c'est pour ça que c'est
après ce thème est en émoi et ces gens
qui m'appellent et me dit comment je
vais gérer sa maîtrise chérie tu fais
comme tout le monde tu fais par un essai
du compte que je présente mes copains
parce que c'est celui que je sais c'est
à dire à toutes les copies défendre
continue à faire du cru comme ça et donc
dans 50 ans il y aura plus mais après ça
et c'est ainsi qu'à ses yeux la or elles
sont toutes mes dixon parce que super
d'être trop j'étais comme un bd depuis
que depuis le début 20 ans que j'ai 73
ans concerne se remettre la chine que
j'ai fait ce n'est jamais arrivé
[Musique]
mouillez vous amenez moi j'avais déjeuné
ensemble dans une baraque
comment ça va je suis beau métal je
définis a tué de dix balles et où je
suis ton père noël tu vas pas me
demander à 73 ans les plus grands et
héros de paris quel baiser tout paris
pendant 40 ans le fait de faute et le
fujian alors un gendre ou d'avoir une
belle fille comme alors deux choses se
calment jean-pierre la première star ac
et le pire c'est thème de votre famille
qui attend le temps était plus lente a
mis tous les gt1 amis de prix à venise
est un ami de tous les tours ans de ces
mes copains chez castel j'ai des copains
bosser seul depuis bien avant existe et
elle ne le dit pas jean-pierre attendre
officiel quelle femme cinq enfants et
les âmes arias il ya trois mois
alors cela dimanche - je peux m'occuper
des enfants
idéalement le père directement mais me
dis enfin pardon que c'est une surprise
totale empêchement que celles que la la
c'est vous qui le prenait pas en compte
la rectrice de surprise totale
on a vécu six mois ensemble entre quant
à bouchard
bah oui pour vous c'était du colloque à
35 ans enfin turc en affaire ici à un
monde où les gens étaient congestionnés
et pendant vingt ans j'ai mickey tout ce
qui bougeait
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si quelques temps ici une légende avec
les mecs
non mais non n'est déjà pas nous mais je
n'étais jamais non plus de la vérité
c'est très bien je n'étais pas le
premier ça va ça va
on s'est engueulés là dessus ghellab à
la salle l'arena
oui mais après tout c'est une arme anti
incendie après il n'a pas de caméra
en attendant il ya pas de caméras mais
papa regarde mon truc enfin senna est
pas allé à l'agencé attend équipe est un
peu
mais original un double recours à l'eau
pour butin c'est maintenant alors oui
c'est bon alors allez c'est maintenant
de gaz parler on s'en fout de ce que
l'iran dément pas il n'y a pas eu assez
de mathieu retrouve également papa lente
et on n'a rien à payer rien un joker
alors aux importantes avec m
par des hypothèses sur la seconde à deux
battants posé perfection pas moi enfin
coutume camera raw jean pierre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les chéris sûr vous allez vivre dans la
deuxième partie je vous jure c'est en
pleurs
je voudrais dire déjà à jean pierre
castaldi est non alors je vous aimez
déjà maintenant c'est pas que je vous
aime
ici c'est que vraiment voilà je vous
embrasse et encore parce que vraiment
qu'est ce que j'aime c'est ok c'est vrai
qu'il est exceptionnel à l'un des plus
grands du coeur de paris la verrai ce
qu'il a fait il a regardé partout et
toujours accolé incroyable je voudrais
féliciter l'équipe c'est comme chacun
sait j'ai fait deux surprise surprise
près le sketch de demi sera une médaille
donc je sais comment ça marche qu'ils
avaient caché sous vague est les fils je
voyais rien pas un fils a été bon
les équipes de leur salaire alors on va
voir les photos de madame ailleurs elle
à partir du moment où je crois que c'est
vrai t'as vu je vais l'aider et c'est
pas fini parce que ça va se corser
yao voir qui va arriver et non il ya une
deuxième jeune fille qui variées vous
allez voir un moment et là c'est le fou
et rassurez vous allez voir qui est
cette deuxième jeune fille ella la
production était très très forte dans le
scénario pour le moment j'ai juste
revoir les les photos sont folles avec
le chien coûtait plus les prix sous ses
poteaux en bas de chez moi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est exceptions les chéris moi j'aime
bien quand on va se retrouver dans un
sport pour la deuxième partie de cette
caméra cachée yapen réactions sur
twitter je vous le dis c'est
complètement ouf
jean michel maire vous allez faire le
facebook lite vous pouvez retrouver jean
michel maire on facebook live tout de
suite grâce à jérôme qui est là bas de
toute la télé point com qui font un
travail fabuleux mais chéri et on se
retrouve dans un instant je vous jure
ne manquez pas la deuxième partie c'est
un film et c'est énorme non vraiment ne
bougeait pas parce qu'on va reprendre
tout de suite après avec la suite à tout
de suite de pilotes pour le moment où
jean pierre castaldi est avec nous en
clair c'est un garçon que j'adore je
vous dis même quand on est un petit peu
en embrouille avec benjamin chaque fois
que je voyais jean-pierre je vois là je
l'embrassé et je l'aimé fort et les deux
ces deux personnages exceptionnels c'est
dommage à main est génial mathieu aussi
vous êtes génial dans la caméra cachée
mais je vous rappelle que si vous nous
rejoignez regarder ce que vous avez pu
voir un instant c'est la première partie
du piège qu'on a tendu à jean-pierre
regarde petit à petit résumé c'est pas
une grosse voiture
oui mais écoute tu es obligé
oh je suis de bancs d'école qu'est ce
que tu vas pas me demander à 73 ans le
plus grand et héros paris qu'à baiser
tout paris pendant 40 ans on était deux
sont des fous de joie d'avoir un gendre
ou non d'avoir une belle fille oui c'est
elle c'est n'en ai pas parlé on s'en fou
de dire nous n'allons pas y apparaît
assez mathieu autres aux élus voilà donc
la main et mathieu qui ont fait croire à
jean-pierre ils étaient ensemble et là
dans un instant il y à aurore il va
arriver une deuxième jeune fille
on verrait vous verrez qu est cette
deuxième jeu de fille jean pierre est ce
que vous y avez cru tout de suite
croix-chapeau êtes vous fait pas de
doutes au départ
bah non c'est long c'est russe était une
blague au départ vraiment vraiment away
c'est au moment où je je vois pas les
caméras
six avions envie 18 18 caméras pas un
fils n ya pas une lumière plus forte que
l'autre créant ce que je n'ai pas
qu'aujourd'hui on peut filmer avec eux
mais ça vous a pas étonnés départ de
benjamin avait serré voilà bah non
apparemment à des problèmes de micros se
tendent à se couper le son la honte à
moi c'est un drapeau vous attend dans ma
génération il est arrivé quelques fois
ta 48 ans je dirais pas les nous
évidemment mais bien sûr à 48 50 ans
parce qu'elle est proche
vous pouvez pas affiché sur la sexualité
comme aujourd'hui on l'a caché j'ai
quelques camarades de jeu en fin de jeu
dans ce que tu dis il ya cru et benjamin
mathieu ont été formidables et celle qui
a été formidable
vous allez avoir tout c'est la femme de
ben arfa de benjamin alors là je peux
vous dire il faut que je lis que deux
jours avant ouais j'en ai parlé avec ma
propre femme
oui d'avoir éventuellement grébé donc à
ce moment là moi je dis mais si ça se
trouve elle est enceinte
oui c'est bien donnez nous des idées
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
maman
c'est donc à lens alors et d'autres pays
et d'autres vous inquiétez pas ça va
bien se passer mais je suis dans ce
temps là où je vois circuler caméra je
ne vais pas m qui tient la main je le
revois la première fois qu'il est humble
on réellement et la deuxième fois hier
soir
et là vous vous dites tout concorde nous
emboîtent joker base à main mathieu
c'est la suite du piège or arrive et une
deuxième jeune fille vous allez voir par
quoi
c'est énorme hélas la première partie
est et non celle ci est vraiment encore
au tibet en août
regardez
[Musique]
bonjour un piège à bettié la tâche était
rentré plus tôt c'est quoi cette valise
un mois ça qui cette bêtise tu te sens
pas c'est bon il est déjà l'heure elle a
acquis cette [ __ ] de valises
les québécois jean-pierre en fait c'est
pas trop près de mazamet m'appeler pour
l'allaiter je n'ai qu'à l'horizon de
très important a dit qu'il y en ait la
voix de l'enfant qu'il y allait avoir un
truc télé paraître sur internet
mais c'est bien en fera la demande en
quoi il allait donc je suis le shérif et
c'est bien regrettable pas pleurer quand
même mais vous avez votre fils là vous
avez votre site
pourquoi je vais me l'annoncer à la 10
minute elle sera transférée
on va comme ça tu bouffes du soucier que
ton père j'ai pas commencé quand même
idée là on s'est tous fait quoi
je viens dit quoi il m'a dit quoi dit
qu'il était amoureux d'un mec tu le sais
pas
[Applaudissements]
laisse tomber
c'est un cauchemar
vie de merde provence
mais c'est ensuite il a affirmé
tardivement et c'est tout ou rien
[Musique]
le calme tu prends tes affaires
tu te casses de chez moi autour de chez
moi aussi moi qui fais pas de bons tours
a cédé pourquoi nous les bonnes
questions mais un jour je sais pas je
sais pas trop
six mois qu'on attend pardon
simon pour combien temps qui n'est pas
l'amour content mais je crains que le
départ mais qu'est ce que tu crois qu'il
aimerait débaucher chez moi qui donne
toujours de fuite raconte qu un tournage
arrive détonne un peu aussi quand je
pense à tes parents
à
casse toi vu chez moi car toi tout de
suite
[Applaudissements]
au mariage servante apparente métis et
ça c'est jean-pierre ils ont bien lâche
manquait plus qu'elle mais c'est qu'il
m'a jazz a rien qui t'es chez moi
mathieu c'est la laisser quitter le
territoire mais tu dis moi que tu
écoutes moi tu me redit encore une fois
de me calmer ce massacre
c'est clair cette fois ça tu dis nous
c'est une personne qui est venue se
faisant pas bien mais c'est quoi cette
bouteille c'est une personne qui vous
ont laissé parce que dans un bain et moi
tu es vraiment du genre plutôt non mais
ça peut relever ensemble d'affaires les
règles mais merde
[Applaudissements]
alors
on va demander de venir ceux importés
ont bondi et la main
j'ai entendu écouté cette personne qui
va te tel jeu nord les soit finir cette
personne non non la pâte au papa et
coûteux - c'est important c'est la mort
mais je ne serais pas arrivé dans le
sahel comme ça qui m'a dit vous verrez
que tous les deux et kate ou même une
honte alors qu'est ce que tu vas me dire
devant la presse
pb non
il n'y a pas encore de bébés quoi je
comprends bien tu dois aux gens c'est
encore ce combat de cyril hanouna qui
tannique et voilà la vérité c'est aux
voix et voilà
voilà qui pourra te croit l'histoire des
montes tu es montagne mois là t'as pas
intérêt militaire et au tennis est
toujours autrement tournée personne
était un terrain perdre à nouveau papa
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je vous jure je ne sais pas sous la
toise et chez nous c'est la cas du rac
acier
je pense franchement c'est la caméra
cachée la plus drôle que j'ai jamais vue
de ma vie mais vraiment manqué aux crocs
et sa fille
il est formidable parce qu'il a quand
même failli en prendre initialement
regarder et même la femme de ben à
savoir garder orale et la femme de m
[Rires]
le franchement dormait et or est
formidable mais jean-pierre vous avez
vous avais les larmes aux yeux en
regardant la caméra c'était pas bien
essayé de protéger son fils colin
maillard dg pas sur la regarder arrivé à
peine arrivé alors on ne peut pas la
voir si lent mais regardez regardez pas
revoir s'extrait de la cam et riou sinon
on fera pas mieux oui vous voyez ce que
je veux même pas en entendre parler
màj mais heureusement je voudrais une
phase un tonnerre d'applaudissements
pour benjamin
[Applaudissements]
on fait un travail exceptionnel
oui mon équipe parce que je n'ai pas vu
sa mère avait lionel chabert et toutes
les équipes d'âge des bandits qui datent
de l'eau
[Applaudissements]